Okay.
I have something very different and unique
for you today.
A Fox News reporter, Chris Wallace has called
out Fox News's totally biased and ridiculous
reporting on the molar report and he did it
while broadcasting on Fox News.
Fox News host calls out Fox News on Fox News.
That's the headline and I want to kind of
set the stage for you here before we get to
the clip.
Fox News is a total right wing propaganda
network that is almost indistinguishable from
the talking points of the Trump administration
at this point in time.
That's the general layout, but there are two,
sometimes a third person, uh, on Fox News
who sometimes are willing to tell pretty uncontroversial
truths, which in the echo chamber that Fox
News has created can actually seem notable
or controversial in some way.
And it's mostly Shepard Smith.
Sometimes it's Chris Wallace.
And every once in a while there's this Fox
News judge named Andrew Nepal a Tano who will
say something accurate.
Recently, he's had some pretty good takes
on the molar report and on obstruction.
And as I've said before, normally when Shep
Smith and Chris Wallace quote, tell the truth,
it's really basic stuff.
Like they point out that a blatant lie by
Donald Trump is a lie.
Okay?
It's relatively uncontroversial.
But on Fox News it gets our attention.
Sometimes when a Trump official is dishonest
shep Smith, we'll just tell us that's not
true.
You're not being told the truth there.
Um, and I've told you that it's a net plus
to have people like Shep Smith and Chris Wallace
on Fox News, but that they're not going to
do any serious questioning of the bigger contextual
issues that make Fox News a problem.
Shep and Chris are what would be called safe
dissenters or, uh, calculated descent so that
Fox News can actually say we're, uh, we're,
we're totally objective and we allow diversity
of opinion and all of that sort of stuff.
But Chris Wallace actually did something interesting
yesterday.
He actually said the opinion programming on
Fox News is pushing a dishonest political
agenda when it comes to the molar report.
And more specifically when it comes to this
letter that we learned about that was sent
by Robert Mueller to William Bar to say, you're
not really representing my report accurately
here.
Um, and here's the clip.
Chris Wallace, again is, is really focusing
on this scathing letter that Robert Mueller
wrote.
We covered the letter yesterday.
Molar makes it clear that what the Justice
Department is doing in terms of its representation
of molars work is not accurate.
And Chris Wallace calls out the opinion side
of Fox News.
You know, I know there's some people who don't
think that the, there's March 27th letter
a is a big deal.
And, uh, you know, some opinion people, some
opinion, people who appear on this network
who may be pushing a political agenda, but
you know, we have to deal in facts.
And, and the fact is that this letter from
the special counsel and it was one of, at
least three contacts with the, uh, attorney
general between, uh, March 25th and March
27th was a clear indication that the attorney
general was upset, very upset
with the letter that bed and sat out by the
attorney general and wanted to change or wanted,
at least added to.
And the attorney general refused to do so.
He felt the attorney general's letter was
inaccurate.
So just to, Chris Wallace actually misspeaks
there and he says the attorney general was
upset with the attorney general.
He met the special prosecutor, Robert Mueller
was upset with the attorney general, but good
for Chris Wallace.
But, but, but there is a button here which
is that Chris Wallace criticized just the
opinion side of Fox News, which is a common
thing that Fox News defenders do.
They say, okay, listen, the opinion side has
a right wing slant and that's okay because
we're counteracting the left wing slant everywhere
else that this is their claim, not mine.
But the news side of Fox News of which Chris
Wallace is apart actually does a really good
job.
And unfortunately the news side has been a
disgrace as well and lists at least power,
less power, less power, uh, from media matters
posted to her Twitter page and example of
the ridiculous coverage from the news side
of Fox News on this issue as well.
Here is a news show on Fox News interviewing
one of the most partisan toxic actors in the
history of presidential investigations.
They interviewed Kenneth Starr, who you might
remember investigated Bill Clinton in the
90s, saying nothing to see here in the molar
report.
Nothing to see here in the molar letter, which
is of course a blatant lie.
And Fox News host bill hemmer allows it on
challenged, including that the letter from
Bullard from Muller to bar is just no big
deal.
So this is the news side being just as much
of a disaster.
Take a look, how do you size this often what
appears to be at least for the moment or a
story of he said, and he said,
sure.
Yeah, it doesn't, uh, I know a lot is being
made out of it, but it looks to me as if at
the end of the day, there's very little, like
this is a 440 plus page report as you pause
through the port, it is so detailed and so
there's nuance there, right?
So it's not surprising that the author of
the report was saying, Hey, you didn't get
it exactly right, but the key is did you get
something wrong?
Or where are you misleading?
Where you an accurate as something that you
said false and their bill bar gets a 100%
great, so he gets an a plus.
Okay.
Justin, absolutely fantastic handling by William
Barr.
So listen, Chris Wallace is right, the opinion
side of Fox News as a total joke on this issue,
but the Fox News news side is just as much
of a joke and maybe dangerously more so because
media literacy is such an abomination in this
country that Fox News viewers are watching
news and thinking they're getting or rather
they're watching what is effectively opinion,
but it's packaged as news and they think they're
getting just the facts and not opinion when
in they're getting the same echo chamber,
a partisan nonsense that Fox News does on
the opinion side.
So again, good for Chris Wallace, a Fox News
host, calling out Fox News on Fox News.
You don't see that every day.
You don't see that every month.
You don't see that every year.
But the implication that the news side, which
Chris Wallace is a part of and wants to protect
from criticism, is doing some great job of
informing us.
Look at Bill Hemmer, stand aside as Kenneth
Starr says the letters, no big deal.
The report is fine.
William bar gets a 100% a plus.
That's the news side that Chris Wallace claims
to be defending absolute and total joke.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Somebody put together a really funny image,
uh, where they added, they photo shopped Sam
cedars glasses onto me and his haircut and
a sweater vest, which I wasn't even actually
aware of with Sam's thing, but I guess he's
known for so that it's this sort of completing
the look of me stealing every element of Sam
Cedars visual presentation and we've posted
it to our Instagram page at David Pakman show.
Make sure you're following us there.
While you're at it, follow me at David dot
pack.
We will take a break and be back to Josh Douglas
Right after this